I'm gonna start with congratulations on
the show we got to see the first two
episodes last night if I had watched
episode three I would push play right
now yep I'm sure I have to I have to ask
you what's it like for you because
originally I heard this was gonna be
like a lifetime two-hour movie and now
this is this massive production with
these huge movie stars you have a good
memory I did sell the rights to my book
a very long time ago and there was talk
about a Lifetime movie
it didn't go forward and then a couple
years ago Michael called me up he bought
the rights and then after that something
else happened that's crucial which is we
saw morning TV we reshaped forever by
the me to movement and I think what we
see now today is the result of all of
those changes you know the evolution for
many years so my book ended up being
just really helpful source material for
the writers to create an entirely new
world in an entirely fictionalized world
of morning TV and it was a thrill for me
too about a consult and help them make
sure this reel of this world is as real
and authentic as possible because
everybody thinks they know morning TV
most people watch morning TV but they
have no idea what happens behind the
scenes um one of the things I want to
talk about specifically is the timing of
this show it I mean we're talking
perfect timing especially with recent
relevation relevé
we know what I'm trying to say which I
cannot seem to utter so talk a little
about the timing of the show and how
relevant it is our business is strange
and so we were in terms of you never
know when you're pursuing and things
will break right the ambition was always
to examine what's mean to be a woman the
media right now was I mean the unique
pressures being a powerful woman in the
media right now and that these shows
were a really amazing backdrop and
setting for that conversation and the me
too you know and then the timing is of
this I think it's no accident Reese
Witherspoon and Jeff Rand were involved
in early stage we were all into
something topical and meaningful and and
then the yeah the moment exploited while
we're making it
and early enough phase though we were
able to respond to it incorporate it and
we hope we've done so meaningful and
responsible way and one of the things
about any TV show in the first season is
you're fit you're basically figuring out
the infrastructure of how do we make
this show what are we able to do and
accomplish in our shooting schedule etc
etc what did you learn while making
season one that maybe you want to apply
for because you already have a two
season pick up as a great question what
we learn season 1 what you learn I think
probably the things we've learned are
what any awfully successful TV show
learns which is you learn how far your
actors can go you learn how far you
you've they're prosaic things about tone
about sensibility about how intelligent
you can be and I think how come
complicated you can be and I think as
you watch the rest of the season what
you'll see is this sewer unique blend of
wickedly entertaining irreverent wild
and then comes back to something real
and meaningful and fine and I think the
show really did an amazing job of
finding that balance and hopefully we
can do more of that going forward you've
done plenty of interviews and obviously
you have a I watch you on TV all the
time I've come curious when was the last
time you got like nervous or really
flustered doing something or does that
not happen anymore with you oh it
definitely still happens it definitely
still happens live TV is unlike anything
else when you are on live TV whether
it's when I'm on CNN or whether you're
on The Today Show or gyum or in America
or whether you're at least Reese
Witherspoon playing our characters on
the morning show live TV is unlike
anything else it's like being on a
tightrope without a net anything can go
wrong at any time I think that's partly
what makes morning TV so interesting
you're on for two hours a day five days
a week so lots of things can go wrong
and for us and for the writers of this
show that creates a lot of drama and a
lot of intrigue that can be mined and it
makes it as you said wickedly
entertaining because there is nothing
like live TV and that note I have to
stop and I'm just gonna say seriously
congratulations on the show cannot wait
to continue watching